sawadika I am hong thaimee follow me to
my tiny table today I'm going to show
you how to make pad thai not only the
original authentic version but I'm gonna
show you how lively and vibrant pad thai
could be it has all the flavors did you
like you know sweetest saltiness and
they came up the spicy and the crunchy
at the end Thai cooking is all about the
balance of the flavor helping grandma in
her kitchen she always balanced
something sours something sweet
something salty in something crunchy
this is where the high heat come to play
sort of cooking the noodle before I
hydrate in a room-temperature water
everything would be cooked in the hot
pan and that is you know the best way
that you can get the best texture of the
noodle pad thai is alive and there's so
many characteristic and personality that
you can put it in and I want to tell
people that cooking Thai food is so
simple straightforward and very easy you
might get overwhelmed by the new
ingredients that you don't know but then
at the end of the day once you know you
can do it on typhoon easily you know pad
thai is a perfect tight ish because
there's an open end of the creativity
did you make into that type you know you
can make it into any kind of cuts how
you like and that means any home cook
can do it that looks so good and then I
evolve all those regular pad thai into a
peptide carbonara we were planning our
brunch menu at my new restaurant tiny
table and you know we was just talking
oh we should do a pet type of radish and
then oh what should we do for brunch
carbonara like oh yeah let's do cut Thai
carbonara
as much as I might I pasta has a
wonderful spot in my heart
who doesn't love pasta and whatever love
noodles how I approach Thai food in
America is something close to my heart
because I was an exchange student and
our goal was we have to give the most of
our Thai culture so I always invite
people in some Thai food I bring Thai
flavors into the American food people
just taste it as you understand so they
can taste the herbs of Thai food the
layer of flavors and everything and
that's how I take it you know it's just
an introduction of a new flavor and the
culture of eating if you want people to
understand the new culture you have to
be part of them the reason that food is
known for an entire culture is it has a
magic to bring everybody together
it's always like home reading pad thai
off the street of Thailand how I grew up
mom and grandma cooked together in the
kitchen with the help of mine you don't
to tell you the truth I think every
family mostly use that time to gather
together when we have family style
every time when there's a big event
people gather together cook together
talk about their life and then after
that you sit down and eat together
and I think like that is the
quintessential of living we come
together we chat we love we exchange
idea and that's the power food
[Music]
you